he barely crawls but baby bashar's
family had to run for safety they
couldn't carry much but what they saved
is the most
precious even if I didn't get anything
most importantly is that my children
have survived more than 200 people from
wed bedan community in the occupied West
Bank were forced to leave their
homes alad says they're used to
defending themselves from settler
attacks but since October the 7th it's
been like nothing they've seen
before they loced us for 4 days we
couldn't bring in water tank to drink it
was a living hell they started telling
us they slaughter us we read on Facebook
calls by settlers to commit a massacre
then they came on October 12th and
attacked the women and children this is
a militia now the community is scattered
in different places Ali his brothers and
their families have relocated to the
Village of TBE 7-year-old KH says he's
the top of his class in
math I ask him what's 3 + 4 he thinks
about it and says it's
7 he says he misses home and
school I want my home
in I don't like it here I don't want to
stay this is the school 9 days after
they left it totally deserted after
settlers attacked it the children say
they missed their toys 11-year-old
Rashid couldn't get his big bicycle the
bins and their cattle have always
depended on a warm climate but it's too
cold here in the village of TBE there's
also little grazing land so they can't
start a new life here some say they're
thinking about leaving the bedwin way of
life
altogether says he already tried to sell
his sheep so he could buy a house for
his three
children I don't know what I'm going to
do later on I haven't thought about it
yet I've always known this work which is
Raising sheep I've never worked in
construction but I might have to now
settler violence has been pushing
Palestinians out of their lands for
years but the attacks have more than
doubled since the Hamas
attack baby Bashar will soon learn to
walk he will also learn that he might
never be able to return to his land
again nid Ibrahim alaz the occupied West
Bank make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer